collègu l'ordre du jour appelle la
question orale de Madame Marie- Thérèse
Brugère madame la ministre des Affaires
sociales et la santé je laisse la parole
à Madame Françoise B en remplacement de
Madame Marie-Thérèse bruguer auteur de
la
question monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre mes chers collègues je prends
donc la parole ce jour suite à un
empêchement de Madame Brugère à laquelle
je souhaite bon rétablissement
un protocole d'accord signé le 29
juillet 2011 engage l'État dans une
reconnaissance des responsabilités des
trois corps de direction de la fonction
publique
hospitalière comme plusieurs
parlementaires j'ai été alerté en
particulier par deux associations de
directeurs des soins qui s'inquiètent et
ce à juste titre sur le devenir de leurs
fonctions et des avancées de leur statut
inquiétude qui ont fait l'objet le 27
mars dernier d'un mouvement social
exceptionnel pour cette catégorie
professionnelle certes les négociations
ont repris suite à ce mouvement avec les
organisations syndicales représentatives
mais les proposition du ministère reste
actuellement toujours en dessa de ce que
la profession est en droit d'espérer
elle demandent à être considéré au même
titre que les deux autres corps de
direction les directeurs des soins œuvre
depuis des décennies avec loyauté force
et conviction pour accompagner les
importantes réformes de notre système de
santé fort de leur expérience des
organisations des soins et de
l'accompagnement des équipes soignante
ils apportent l'éclairage nécessaire à
l'évolution des structures en
particulier au sein du
directoire il est important de prendre
en compte le fait que ces professionnels
sont en troisè partie de carrière
carrière souvent longue après un
parcours de soignant puis de cadres et
ne peuvent exercer leur fonction que 20
ans en moyenne l'Association française
des directeurs de soins a pris acte
desavancés notamment sur le logement
puisque le décret a supprimé la mesure
d'exception les
concernant par contre les résultats
obtenu sur la grille indicière sont en
desessà de leurs espérances même si les
association reconnaisse que l'adoption
de l'indice 105 est un premier pas en
effet la grille salariale qui leur est
proposé ne reconnaît pas leur niveau de
responsabilité que ce soit auprès des
établissements de soins ou à la tête des
instituts de formation aux professions
de santé paramédicaux ou encore dans les
ARS la baisse régulière et préoccupante
des candidats au concours annuel en est
la
preuve c'est la raison pour laquelle les
directeurs de soins souhaitent une
grille identique aux directeurs
d'hôpitaux sans pour autant revendiquer
un statut identique il s'agit là pour
l'État autant d'un problème de respect
de sa parole dans le cadre du protocole
du 29 juillet 2011 que d'un souci de
reconnaître à son juste niveau les
responsabilités et l'engagement de ses
agents s'ajoute le problème de
l'évolution démographique de cette
profession
touché par les restructurations
hospitalières et budgétaires d'une part
d'autre part pour des raisons de
revalorisation statutaire inexistant
jusqu'à présent le nombre de postes de
directeur de soins est passé de 901 en
2011 à 830 début
2013 ils sont sur des fonctions
recentrées dans le cadre de l'évolution
des structures mais comme le soulligne
entre autres le Centre national de
gestion et l'association des directeurs
d'hôpitaux la vacance de poste qui
s'amplifie est une
préoccupation aussi tant sur l'évolution
de la grille indiciaire que sur le
problème préoccupant du déclin
démographique de cette profession par
manque d'attractivité pouvez-vous madame
le ministre nous préciser vos intentions
et surtout rassurer les professionnels
du secteur avec l'apparition des textes
proposés la parole est à Madame
Dominique Bertinotti ministre chargé de
la famille madame la sénatrice les 860
directeurs des soins dont le statut et
les grilles indiciaaires en vigueur date
d'avril 2002 ont vu au cours de ces
dernières années leur positionnement et
leur mission se se renforcer dans
l'organisation et le fonctionnement de
l'hôpital leur contribution va être
essentiel dans l'optimisation du
parcours de soins des patients il s'agit
là d'un élément fort de la stratégie
nationale de santé que le gouvernement
met en œuvre actuellement la réforme du
statut des directeurs de soins et
l'amélioration de leur rémunération sont
donc justifié ainsi cette réforme
décidée par le gouvernement et qui a
fait l'objet d'une présentation au
Conseil supérieur de la fonction
publique hospitalière en juillet dernier
correspond d'une part à une
revalorisation des grilles de
rémunération du corps et d' d'utre part
à la création d'un statut d'emploi
fonctionnel concernant le corps
l'ensemble des agents va pouvoir
atteindre un échelon terminal fixé à
l'indice brut 1015 au lieu de l'indice
920 précédemment cette revalorisation du
corps va se faire en deux temps tout
d'abord un reclassement dans les
nouvelles grilles du corps à comptter de
la publication du texte et deuxièmement
le relèvement indiciire en juillet 2015
la durée de carrière et les modalités
d'avancement tiennent compte de la
particularité de ce corps qui constitue
une troème carrière pour certains
personnels de la Fonction Publique
Hospitalière quant au statut d'emploi
fonctionnel madame la sénatrice il va
bénéficier à 100 directeurs des soins
sur les 860 personnels en poste trois
emplois de directeur des soins assurant
les plus hautes fonctions du corps à
l'Assistance Publique des Hôpitaux de
Paris aux Hospices Civils de Lyon et à
l'assistance publique hôpitaux de
Marseille seront qualifiés dans un
groupe d'emploi fonctionnel atteignant
la hors échelle lettre B 97 emplois dans
les établissements de soins et dans les
institut de formation les plus
importants seront qualifiés dans un
groupe d'emploi atteignant la hors
échelle lettre A madame la ministre des
Affaires sociales et de la santé
veillera personnellement à ce que les T
permettant la mise en œuvre de ces
mesures soit publiée d'ici la fin de
l'année
merci
madame je me réjou pour les avancements
qui sont prévus et pour l'application
des textes je transmettrai donc tous ces
éléments à Madame bruguierre merci merci
mes chers collègues